striking fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere folks
[Applause]
liberals beware this is typical manga
[ __ ] just like the the video i have up
here on the screen typical [ __ ] they
think like this is this is um if you
look here close this is don junior here
uh booger sugar junior you know the
cokehead that is
uh donald trump's the former president's
son
uh who who who is the laptop we should
actually be looking for the cell phone
and the burners we should actually be
looking for the projection is strong
with this one and then we have eric
greitens
the the sex assaulter you know the the
former disgraced missouri governor who
duct taped his hairdresser to his
treadmill in his basement made her get
naked and took pictures of her while she
was blindfolded
and then
made her do sex acts
so that way he could use the pictures as
blackmail yeah that guy that [ __ ] guy
right there
eric greitens and don't don't believe me
when i say this [ __ ] about eric greitens
believe the republicans in missouri the
republicans in missouri are the ones who
did the investigation against eric
greitens and published the findings
which found that he duct taped his
hairdresser naked blindfolded to a
treadmill in his basement i'm not
[ __ ] you that [ __ ] is real you know
what else is real eric greitens is
running for united states senate in the
state of missouri
and kimberly guilfoyle is part of his
campaign or some [ __ ]
that's why booger sugar jr here decided
to go up and have a tough guy moment on
camera because that's all this is
you ever met the guy in a bar who talks
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] who's gonna beat
everyone's ass oh he's gonna kick your
ass and he's gonna kick your ass and
he's gonna do this and he's gonna do
that all that [ __ ] and then you get
out on the sidewalk and that that
[ __ ] gets his face pounded in
because he's all [ __ ] talk
all talk
yeah that's what these two are all
[ __ ] talk
everyone's saying this is dangerous and
of course it's [ __ ] dangerous because
they're sending a dog whistle
to people who are actually [ __ ]
dangerous
who would actually do the [ __ ] that
they're saying in the video
that's what they're doing here folks
they wouldn't actually do it they're a
bunch of [ __ ] they get their asses
kicked on the sidewalk in front of a bar
eric greitens and donald trump jr both
let's just watch this video let me make
it bigger for you so you can see
all the nonsense in this video
listen really closely to what don jr
says and then listen to what eric
greitens says we'll watch it a couple
times so you can catch it
oh so tough so tough they can shoot a
target woo baby bang bang bang bang bang
pew pew pew pew pew no liberal can pick
up a gun and shoot a target that's not a
thing liberals just can't handle guns
and shoot get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] liberals own guns dummies
liberals own a lot of [ __ ] guns
and frankly liberals are smarter with
their [ __ ] weapons i would say and
probably have less accidents fatal
accidents for that matter but let's
listen to what don jr says here strikes
your fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere striking fear in the hearts
of liberals everywhere i you i don't
fear you you dumb [ __ ] and
honestly if i was ever approached by
would with donald trump jr and he had a
[ __ ] rifle in his hand it would just
piss me off more than anything it would
piss me off more for him to approach me
if he had a firearm than if he didn't
have one it would just piss me off more
and i feel that way about anyone with a
firearm if you got to walk around with a
[ __ ] firearm so you can order a
subway sandwich you are a [ __ ] you are
a [ __ ] weak piece of [ __ ] you are a
[ __ ] snowflake if you gotta carry
around a gun feel tough
that's what you are
just like donald trump booger sugar
junior here
and eric greitens in tow listen to what
this [ __ ] says
beware
did you catch it
did you catch it he said liberals beware
liberals beware let's listen strike your
fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere in the heart of the striking
fear and the hearts of liberals
everywhere and then listen
liberals beware liberals beware what a
bunch of [ __ ]
what a bunch of goddamn snowflake
[ __ ]
but they have to
oh and a bunch of [ __ ] boxes they think
they're so [ __ ] tough
they think liberals are scared a
boneheads with guns you are a dumb
stupid son of a [ __ ]
if you think liberals are scared with a
of a bunch of boneheads with guns really
[ __ ] stupid